The Joe Rogan experience.
I remember the first day that, uh, I was at Twitter, um,
the, at the time, uh,
the most popular person on Twitter was Justin Bieber.
He had more followers than any other person, you know.
Was that when you guys were trying to rig it so that he wasn't, uh,
trending number one, always. Cause they did do that. Right.
I don't remember that. I was, Oh, I don't remember conveniently.
They.
Me and I were talking about that one day because they had to do something
because they didn't do something.
Justin Bieber would be the number one topic every day,
no matter what was happening in the world.
I believe that they wanted to change that because the pro the problem was at the
time Twitter was held together with like, you know,
bubble gum and like dental floss or whatever, you know?
So it's like every time Bieber would tweet, like, you know,
the lights would dim and like the building, like kind of shake a little bit.
There it goes. So they block me from trending. This is 2010.
I'm actually honored. Not even Matt. He's also 12.
Then I get on and see yet again, my fans are unstoppable. Love you. Okay.
But, okay. So there's, you know, people talk about like invisible labor,
like the invisible labor behind that tweet.
It was just kind of comical because it's like, when he did that, you know,
people like, you know, it's like my first day there, you know, it's like he,
he tweeted something and, you know, the building's like kind of shaking it.
Like alarms are going off. People are like scrambling around, you know?
And it was just this, you know,
it's like this realization where you're just like, never in my life.
Did I think that anything Justin Bieber did would like really affect me in any
like deep way, you know? And then here I am just like scrambling around to like,
facilitate that.
What are your thoughts on curating?
What trends and what doesn't trend and whether or not social media should
have any sort of obligation in terms of
how things,
whether or not people see things like shadow banning and things along those
lines. Like, I I'm very torn on this stuff cause I, I,
I think that things should just be,
and if you have a situation where Justin is the most popular thing on the
internet, that's just what it is. It is what it is.
But I also get it. I get how you would say, well,
this is going to up our whole program.
Like what we're trying to do with this thing.
What do you mean up our whole program?
Well, what you're trying to do with Twitter, I mean,
I would assume what you're trying to do is give people a place where they could
share important information and, uh, you know, have people,
you know, I mean,
Twitter has been used successfully to overturn governments.
I mean, there there's,
there's Twitter has been used to break news on very important events and
alert people to danger. And there's,
there's so many positive things about Twitter. And if,
if it's overwhelmed by Justin Bieber and Justin Bieber fan accounts,
and just to be repo,
if it's overwhelmed and the top 10 that are trending are all
nonsense.
I could see how someone would think we're going to do a good thing
by suppressing that. Yeah,
I see what you're saying. Well, why do you think they did suppress that?
What do you think you work there? Why do you think they kept him from trending?
Um, well, I mean, I don't know about that specific situation.
I mean, I think, I think, you know, looking at the larger picture, right? Like,
um, in a way, you know, it's like, if you think about like 20 years ago,
whenever anybody talked about like society, you know, um,
everyone would always say like, the problem is the media.
It's like the media man. Yeah. If only we could change the media.
And a lot of people in who were interested in like
a better and brighter future were really focused on self-publishing their whole
conferences about it on ground underground publishing conference.
Now the allied media conference, people were writing scenes. Uh, people were,
you know, getting their own printing presses, uh, people, you know, we,
we were convinced that if we, um,
made publishing more equitable,
if everybody had the equal ability to like produce and consume content that the
world would change. And in some ways,
like what we have today is like the fantasy of,
you know, those dreams from 20 years ago. Um,
but in a couple of ways, you know, like, uh, one, you know,
it was, it was, it was the dream that if, you know,
a cop kill some random person in the suburbs of St.
Louis that like everyone would know about it, you know, um, just,
you know, everyone knows. Um,
and also that anybody could share their weird ideas about the world, you know?
And I think in some ways, um, we were wrong, you know,
that we thought, uh, like, you know, the, what we got today is like, yeah,
like if a cop kills somebody in the suburbs of St. Louis,
like everybody knows about it.
I think we overestimated how much that would matter. Uh,
and I think we also believed that the things that everyone would be sharing
for like our weird ideas about the world. And instead we got like, you know,
flat earth then like, you know, uh anti-vax and like, you know, all this stuff.
Right. Uh, and so it's like, in a sense, like,
I'm glad that those things exist because they're like,
they're sort of what we wanted, you know? Uh, but I think what we did,
what we underestimated is like how, uh, important the medium is,
like the medium is the message kind of thing. And that,
like what we were doing at the time of like, you know,
writing scenes and sharing information,
I don't think we understood how much that was predicated on like actually
building community and like relationships with each other. And that like, just,
um, like what we didn't want was just like more channels on the television and
that's sort of what we got, you know? Uh, and so I think, you know,
it's like everyone is like on YouTube trying to monetize their content,
whatever know, and that it's the same thing,
like bad business models produce like bad technology and bad outcomes.
And so I think there's concern about that, but I think,
um, I think like, you know,
now that there's, there's like, you know,
these two simultaneous truths that everyone seems to believe that are in
contradiction with each other, you know, like one is that like, um,
everything's relative, uh, everyone is entitled to their own opinion.
All opinions are equally valid. And to like, um,
our democracy is impossible without a shared understanding of what is true and
what is false,
the information that we share needs to be verified by our most trusted
institutions. You know,
like people seem to simultaneously believe both of these things and, um,
they are in direct contradiction with each other. Um,
and so in some ways I think most of the questions about, you know,
social media in our time are about like trying to resolve those contradictions.
And, but I think, you know, um,
I think it's way more complicated than the way, uh,
that the social media companies are trying to portray.
Catch new episodes of the Joe Rogan experience for free only on Spotify,
watch back catalog J R E videos on Spotify,
including clips easily seamlessly switch between video
and audio experience on Spotify.
You can listen to the JRE in the background while using other apps and can
download episodes to save on data costs.
All for free Spotify is absolutely free.
You don't have to have a premium account to watch new JRE episodes.
You just need to search for the JRE on your Spotify app.
Go to Spotify now to get this full episode of the Joe Rogan experience.